you know why most people don't win I
don't bother you know why most people
don't win they don't bother you have to
bother it to be intentional you want to
have an incredible marriage you have to
be intentional about it you want to have
incredible kids you have to be
intentional about it you think about it
you read about it you study about it you
spend your time on it you want to be in
great physical condition you have to be
intentional about it you think about
what you eat and how you exercise you
think about how you take care of your
body you set goals you want one with
money you want to win with money you
want to have some you want to be wealthy
the weird thing is in our culture we're
so stinking prosperous that you can be
mediocre and stupid and still make money
I mean we grade on such a curve in this
culture that you can really you can
really be pretty much a doofus and make
it not bother not care half but do
things no sense of excellence no
self-improvement and you could still end
up having some money but if you bother
if you're intentional you tell your
money what to do instead of wondering
where it went you write it down on paper
on purpose before the month begins you
decide I'm getting out of debt why
because all my money goes out in
payments I don't have any money and my
most powerful wealth building tool is my
income when I give it all to someone
else I don't have the ability to build
wealth so based on that I'm going to
decide to not have a car payment I'm
going to decide to not have a student
loan I'm going to decide if I have those
things to get them paid off I'm going to
get the credit cards out and chop them
up have a plastic to me baby plastic
surgery I'm going to make some
statements intentionality about what I'm
going to do with my life we're going to
intentionally save we're going to learn
the numbers like if I invest $100 a
month from age 25
h-65 $100 a month latte breath you spend
that on cable and pizza shut up
$100 a month from age 25 to age 65 and a
decent growth stock mutual fund put it
in a Roth IRA you're gonna have one
million one hundred and seventy six
thousand dollars if it averages 12%
there's no excuse to not retire a
millionaire in this culture $100 a month
nineteen ahangar gathers well you're not
intentional about it you paying it all
out to other people you live impulse to
impulse thank God it's Friday - oh god
it's money I know I used to do this
stuff and you're freaking broke
make $80,000 here got nothing got
nothing make you $70,000 a year $50,000
a year one hundred and fifty thousand
dollars you got nothing cuz you didn't
bother intention ality moves the needle
Earl Nightingale said you become what
you think about Jesus said as a man
thinketh in his heart so is he
what are you intentionally going to do
with your career you know if you
bothered to care about your career you'd
be at work ten minutes or at least eight
ten minutes late and actually work while
you at work and get off the freakin
Facebook I don't know how you people get
anything done between your Twitter
account your Facebook account try
working while you're at work you'll
stand out because nobody else does try
working telling the truth and smiling
while you're at work you'll get a
promotion in a month because you're
standing among a bunch of cows and all
of a sudden you'll stick up and look you
won't look like a cow anymore you stand
out from the herd tell the truth smile
and work while you're at work
wow what a culture we live in that it's
that easy to be a big dog you do that
for 15 years you can change your whole
family tree you
it for 15 days people will start
noticing it you do it for 15 weeks
you'll be running the whole place all
right you know what I'm talking about if
you take that piece of information I can
drop you in the middle of any city let
you get any menial job at any little
stupid thing you do and pretty soon
you'll be running the place or owning
the place just because you're
intentional you do become what you think
about bother bother to care tell your
money what to do don't be sitting down
and looking at your tax return and going
we may do you [ __ ] those mothers but
somebody tell me we're with well you
lost it because you pissed it away you
had no idea what you're doing you're
lost as a ball and tall weeds you watch
38 hours of television every week you
know exactly who got thrown off the
island but you don't know what happened
here $85,000 how's that for stupid
that's stupid America it's stupid and
then sit around and whine and act like a
victim and act like somebody did
something to you nobody did anything to
you
roll up your sleeves and be a grown-up
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good if you will
bother you can have a fabulous marriage
you can have great kids you can have
money and a career in that meat there's
a few things you can't control no matter
how hard I think about it I can't grow
my hair back it's gone there's a few
things you can't control other people's
actions and they run their car into
yours you can't control that but you can
control how you react in those
situations and you can be intentional
about your character your work ethic you
can be intentional and tell every one of
those dollars you are going over here
you are going over here you are going
over here you're going to be given away
in a tithe at my church you're you over
here you're gonna you're going to be in
the kids college fund you got you you
walk right over there you're going to
buy food and we tell everyone those
dollars what to do you
one of them a mission on paper on
purpose before the month begins nobody
does that
I know and nobody has any freaking money
because they don't have a plan if you
worked for you incorporated as a
business and you incorporated your job
there was to manage money and you
managed money for you incorporated the
way you manage money for you
incorporated now would you fire you
don't answer that it's pitiful
it's just pitiful I used to do it too I
know what pitiful looks like I know what
stupid looks like I used to seem in the
mirror pretty regularly when I went
broke I sat around trot whined and
blamed everybody else I feel like it's
somebody else's fault
then one day I grew up and realized it
was my fault
the stuff that happened to me old people
did stuff to me I was betrayed and lied
to had all these things happen but you
know what I put myself in a position
that those things could happen I don't
enter into partnerships anymore and I
don't deal with bankers anymore unless
I'm buying their bank only time I deal
with them to open a checking account
that's it I buy real estate off of them
that they had to foreclose on I'm not in
there asking for mercy because I'm not
going to put myself in a position I need
their mercy because they don't have any
of that in their bucket intention ality
people you won't live without a credit
card
pretty simple get your debit card and
have a budget and don't have any
payments you'll have money average car
payment America's four hundred eighty
six dollars over eighty four months
right now according the national auto
dealers association you take four
hundred eighty six dollars invested in a
decent growth stock mutual fund from age
thirty to age 70 you'll have five point
six million dollars in your Roth IRA
hope you like the freakin car five
million freakin dollar car you're
driving there then scratching your head
and wondering why your kids college fund
isn't fund it but you impress somebody
to stoplight you'll never meet stupid
that's what that is stupid
you know what normal is stupid I don't
want to be normal be intentional and
excellent and passionate and if some of
you don't like that I'll be okay with it
by the way some of you don't like it and
I'm okay with it
life's good cuz we made it that way so
shut up take control of your destiny go
be somebody on purpose this is the Dave
Ramsey show